there's much to praise about the remake
of demon souls
it's a remarkable technical showpiece
for the playstation 5 a gripping
gameplay experience that oscillates
between exhilarating
nerve-wracking and downright
heartbreaking and a faithful recreation
of the seminal title that birthed the
souls-like sub-genre
but developer bluepoint's greatest
achievement is that it took something
i'm intimately familiar with
and made me feel like i was venturing
into the unknown
[Music]
fundamentally demon souls for ps5 is
what it always has been
firing some small tweaks the design of
the game is identical to from software's
original
the core mechanics are unchanged the
enemies are placed in the same positions
and behave in the same ways
and the devious tricks and traps are
still there ready to catch the
unfamiliar off guard
but what makes it special is how blue
point has applied its own creative
vision to from software's original
to remake the game not just as it was
but as it was meant to be
realizing its full potential the result
is a title that pays homage to from
software's work
but at the same time stands as brilliant
in its own right
every facet of the environment is rich
even the people who occupy the nexus
have more detail which in turn gives
them greater depth
stockpile thomas a four-long figure who
sits in the nook of the nexus and offers
to look after your excess items and
equipment
tells his story in a way that was not
possible before
my wife and daughter phil
wrecked him to the demons this is the
first time
in many hours of playing demon souls
that i've been able to read the
expression on thomas's faces
and the pain is visible as he recounts
his tragic loss
though their lines may be brief the
voices of these characters sound
familiar
and while some have been re-recorded
with the same actors others are new
but it all sounds right and where new or
tweaked writing and vocal performances
appear
they still evoke the intended effect
where do you call home
dear me i shouldn't pry that is true of
every area in the game
each of the five archstones takes you to
locales that are jaw-dropping visually
and distinct atmospherically this is a
game that in numerous ways
serves as a showcase for all of the ps5
signature features
and hearing demon souls is as gratifying
as seeing and playing it
thanks to the 3d audio through
headphones the heavy
threatening breathing of a blue-eyed
knight told me it was nearby
before i could even see it buzzing flies
and the ragged cores of pecking crows
made the sight of a decaying horse
carcass all the more unsightly
and as archer's fired arrows the sounds
of them whizzing by my ears reveal just
how narrowly i escaped
crucially in each location these new
effects
beautiful lighting and gorgeous
modelling never upend from software's
intent
and in fact create a truer
representation of it
advancement in technology and game
design have given blue point tools to do
what from software couldn't
on ps3 back in 2009 the maze of tunnels
in stone fang feels even more
claustrophobic
and as you venture deeper the rippling
steam coming off lava makes the
sweltering hot environments feel
oppressive
the valley of the firemen's wet wooden
scaffolding looks perilous to walk along
and the torches burn bright blue
violently moving as if agitated
by an unseen toxic gas you feel gross
just standing there
bosses are treated with the same kind of
care either true to the original
or change to more closely embody the
spirit of it the vanguard looks less
like one of those rubber monsters in my
pocket toys from the 90s and more like a
disgusting demonic executioner
the tower knight looms above you
striking a presence that is both heroic
and terrifying
the flame lurker fight because of how
good the animation work is
made me feel like i was a matador
trapped in a lava pit with a demonic
flaming bull constantly bearing down on
me
technically demon souls is astounding on
performance mode it displays gorgeous
visuals rendered at 1440p and upscaled
to 4k
at a consistent smooth frame rate
cinematic mode runs at native 4k
but this seems to come at the cost of
performance as i found the frame rate to
be much less consistent
i stuck to performance mode and did so
with the new offset camera view
which i found to frame the game in a
more cinematic way
features such as the ability to make the
ui dynamically fade in and out do a
great deal
to improve immersion there are also
multiple graphic filters available
including the more muted greener palette
of the original ps3 release
although i think blue point's version
with its richness and vibrancy
should be the way you play for the first
time through if it wasn't clear
demon souls on ps5 is one of the best
looking and sounding games i've ever
played
outside of the presentation bluepoint
has employed a deft to touch
as mentioned previously demon souls on
ps5 plays very much the same
mechanically speaking however bluepoint
has clearly spent a great deal of effort
on improving the feedback
so everything is more impactful there's
a weightiness and heft to the game that
has communicated visually and through
audio
everything from movements to attack
evasion and even consuming item has a
physicality to it
there's a real sense of inertia and
momentum as your blade cuts through the
air
and noticeable resistance as it meets
the steel of armor or the flesh of an
enemy
the visual feedback also instills a
greater sense of danger
you don't want to get hit by things
because it looks and sounds like it
hurts
the physicality now supports and
reinforces the deliberate methodical
nature of souls combat
and that's what stripped me of some of
my confidence the difference in the way
it feels
along with actually being a little rusty
has forced me to once again respect
demon souls
because it's as ruthless as it has ever
been and in many cases more ruthless
than the souls games that followed it
new additions such as unique attack and
finisher animations give weapons more of
an identity than they
had in the original and landing repulse
is such a rush that you want to try and
parry every single enemy
[Music]
but by sticking so closely to from
software's framework bluepoint has also
carried forward some of the more
idiosyncratic aspects of demon souls
gameplay experience
although world tendency is explained a
bit better and more readily visible to
the player
that doesn't make the underlying issues
of it any better it's still for all but
the most learned players quite obtuse as
a concept
the idea of a player struggling dying
and the game becoming harder because of
black world tendency as a result is
suspect
but it's still nonetheless intact in the
remake demon subs for ps5 also features
the same finicky multiplayer system that
it had on ps3
and that from software games continue to
have there are specific conditions that
need to be met and items employed to
enable jolly cooperation
but the information around this isn't
surfaced in a clear visible way for
newcomers to understand
it then falls upon the player to figure
it out but i can't fault bluepoint for
leaving it untouched
warts and all the studio is in the
unenviable position of remaking one of
the most beloved games of all time
which has an incredibly passionate and
vocal fan base and what might seem like
a reasonable change to one person
could be an undermining of what makes
the game unique distinct and memorable
to another
quirks aside blue points remake is an
unmitigated success
it is a technical tour de force and a
true showpiece for what the ps5 and the
power of sony's next-gen console can do
but more importantly it's also a
creative marvel coming from a studio
that is clearly showing the world it has
its own voice
bluepoint is taken from software's
original game and expressed it in a
richer fuller way
and in doing so given me something that
i thought was impossible
the opportunity to relive the experience
of falling in love with souls games for
the first time
[Music]
you